Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie hopefully you've
all had a chance to see Doctor Strange by
now so this is going to be my top picks for
what I think they should do next with the
character, especially considering Avengers
Infinity War.
Just careful for spoilers for everything that
happened during Doctor Strange.
So the really exciting thing is we're already
going to be seeing some Doctor Strange really
soon, we know that because the Post Credits
Scene, so number one just flat out hold off
on a direct Doctor Strange sequel like Doctor
Strange 2 until Phase 4 because you have about
eight more films and Phase 3 that go up till
May 2019 that'll be the second Avengers Infinity
War film leaving the fall of 2019 like later
that year or whatever they want to start Phase
4 with so right off the bat.
They can start fall 2019 with Doctor Strange
to and pick up on some of the big things that
they tease that were happening at the end
of the first Doctor Strange movie that's really
like the easiest thing for them to do because
they do have to follow up on those plot threads
the biggest ones being the threat of Dormammu,
which will talk about in the second because
I don't think that he's going to be a big
villain for a long long time into the more
immediate threat of Baron Mordo though killing
off magic users.
So I think in a like next big Doctor Strange
movie will be Doctor Strange versus Baron
Mordo.
And it'll be the culmination of his ascension
to Sorceror Supreme because at the end of
this movie even though he wielded the Eye
of Agamotto the time gem the ancient one said
that she saw great potential in him he is
not the Sorcerer Supreme.
So currently there is not one on earth right
now a lot of that arc will take place over
the course of Phase 3 so.
Just like the Hulk gets like a really big
story stretched out over bunch of other people's
films.
Doctor Strange's story of his ascension to
source or supreme kind of crossover a bunch
of films but a lot of times though save the
biggest twist for characters for their solo
films in becoming sorcerer supreme is a huge
deal.
So they would probably say that moment like
that final moment of that when he become sorcerer
supreme for the next Doctor Strange movie.
But I know I just talked about Dormammu, we
know that he's a big threat what I think is
going to happen I think were all kind of in
agreement that he's such a big threat that
they'll just save him like the next big thing
after they Enos the directors got Garrison's
even having a little bit of fun with that
idea to, so the heroes will deal with Enos
during both of the infinity war films, then
Dormammu will slowly move in and become a
bigger threat, so number three Doctor Strange
in Thor Ragnarok crossover movie it's really
more of a Thor movie with Doctor Strange and
it like you said the row phase 3 will see
a lot of Doctor Strange sometimes it will
be very brief.
Sometimes it will be much bigger door you
can think of it as a big crossover because
it's a pretty big plot point helping them
track down Odin on earth so that they can
get back to Asgard deal with Hela in the Ragnarok
monsters swallowed and say I'm totally cool
with them pushing off a direct Doctor Strange
sequel, so they can do more stuff like that
more team of movies and Kevin fight he did
tease that the phase for movie is will look
a lot different from the way they structured
the phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 movies which I
think just means a lot more team ups like
even if we don't see and Iron Man SQL actually
although it's a number four Doctor Strange
Iron Man team up which I think is a good option
for both actors because at this point Robert
Downey Junior is so expensive and he's getting
to the age where it's like you know what kind
of story haven't we done yet what is there
that he's capable of doing that people want
to buy movie tickets for.
So I just think the idea of working with Benedict
Cumberbatch would excite Robert Downey Junior
enough to get them to do a movie.
So the problem with that is that if you gonna
put Iron Man and Doctor Strange in a movie
together and it's gonna be like their buddy
road trip comedy movie you need to have a
villain with 1 foot in the realm of science
and 1 foot in the realm of magic and who is
that in the marvel universe will that is Doctor
Doom and they don't have access to him right
now he will be a perfect villain for Doctor
Strange Iron Man team up, but I'm not can
hold my breath for Fox sharing the character
so they might be able to do a version of the
Mandarin all the 10 rings they did that short
film called hail to the King where they tease
the idea that there is a real Mandarin who
is in the world somewhere we just haven't
seen them yet.
And who knows if will have her surface.
But if you read some of the Furor over the
recasting of Tilda Swinton like the way they
cast that character how like a lot of people
felt like it was really insensitive there
was a whole bunch of drama behind it.
Just imagine them trying to do the Mandarin
character and then selling the movie in China.
So it just a huge land mind that they don't
want to step on.
So even though it would be awesome to see
the Mandarin whose rings come from an alien
race.
So there's your science right there but there
also imbued with their own level of intelligence.
So you have some supernatural so you know
Mandarin would be a good villain for Doctor
Strange Iron Man team up as long as he did
at the 10 rings but I don't do that Marvel's
going to do that they might just save you
know Doctor Strange Iron Man team up solo
film for whenever they can get a villain that
they feel like his big enough or they can
actually get Doctor Doom flat out but Kevin
Feige himself was just saying how excited
he was at the thought of Benedict Cumberbatch
and scenes as Doctor Strange with Robert Downey
Junior is Tony Stark just seen those two characters
interact with each other and seeing how crazy
it gets.
So will actually get a taste of that when
we get to infinity war so still little ways
off but it's coming next big idea is a Doctor
Strange multi-verse treasure hunt treasure
hunt is always a ton of fun in a very swashbuckling
adventure, but because his Doctor Strange
he's not bound by time or space he can go
all over the multi-verse if you remember the
2001 space Odyssey montage were the ancient
what is kind like pushes him on a trip through
the multi-verse is to give them a taste of
what's out there.
Just imagine a pretty straight up treasure
hunt story where he's tracking down dangerous
magical artifacts along the way he crosses
paths with people like Mephisto Dormammu again
just a little bit you want to keep him off
in the distance you don't do too much and
too soon, but that would be more like a straight
up national treasure type story with Marvel
characters so would be quite is crazy.
But then you note the last big idea would
be like a team magic film.
So if you really wanted to you could do like
a Baron Mordo Loki team up against Doctor
Strange Scarlet Witch and any of the other
magical characters that we see along the way
because their lot characters they just haven't
introduced yet.
So really, you could put anyone in that movie
who has the power of an infinity gem that
you depending on what their status is after
the second infinity war film but I know I'm
your wondering like what about comic book
story is what you most of the stuff that they
do in the movies or a mall gum's of comic
books.
And we've already seen all this big stuff
that they set up in the first film like staff
of the living tribunal all these magical artifacts
story points like Dormammu.
What's going on with Baron Mordo they have
to carry those forward so largely you kind
of know what the going to be doing with any
sequel that they do.
But the other big thing is just mixing and
the other Marvel characters like we kinda
saw some Marvel verse stuff happening during
Doctor Strange but just like Ant Man was its
own little small thing by itself.
So was Doctor Strange so now the job.
Just like sticking Ant Man in Civil War with
all these of the characters is doing the same
thing with Doctor Strange like mixing his
universe with everyone else's, so let me know
what you want them to do for the next Doctor
Strange movie and do you think that they suggest
try to use him in big crossovers like they're
doing with the Iron Man character like Iron
Man is going to pop up during a bunch of different
films like Spider-Man homecoming the Avengers
films but thus far, they've said nothing about
doing another solo Iron Man film so I think
the closest thing will get is like a really
big team up with another character the we
haven't seen Iron Man interact with before,
which would be Doctor Strange what can happen
next.
Though is tomorrow the be some new Game of
Thrones they acturally just announced that
Emilia Clarke is going to be in the Star Wars
Han Solo movie.
They didn't say who she is going to play though
and there will be new Walking Dead.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my Doctor Strange Easter Eggs
and you can click here for really cool Tom
Holland Spider Man Homecoming interview thank
you so much watching everybody let's high
five from behind the screen I'll see you guys
tomorrow!